it's a two-pronged approach the first
part involves seeing stellar bay
properly defended and a mantis or
problem and a Marauder problem many many
problems but they can all be solved with
a bolt 52 cartridge if you can get us
what we need to rejoin the board
starting vault 52 will be able to become
one of the most productive and secure
cities in Halcyon and you'll have a
powerful ally on the board quite one of
the strongest defense in the old arms
building south west of town which used
to be part of stellar bay do be careful
I've lost mope oh and while you're at it
there should be a terminal in the arms
building with some dangerous infamy
you
you
you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh I hear boats out there
wait traps reboot
oh thank you my friends and I was
scavenging here and a medic I ran in
here
easier than it yeah my buddy had a team
but I ain't hurt
no look for a dead guy I guess for a
wrap
probably I don't know Mike but
actually I'm gonna Kanna
Oh
what
wait ah you thank you so much it was
getting all stuffy in there and I was
getting a mite lightheaded and I think
maybe I was gonna die now I'm out here
I'm headed back to amber Heights
but I ain't got enough
Thanks
something you need
you
[Music]
find it
she wore it's supposed to
oh this has I give Amos but I thought
apparently in shop
I had thank you oh yes I'm going to be
up all night with this all those blanks
waiting to be filled boxes waiting to be
ticked try to control yours